have you bought a Nintendo switch or
anything else on GameStop's website
that's gamestop not gamespot well if you
have then your credit card information
may be at risk as the company has
confirmed a possible security breach I'm
Matt and this gamespot news update is
perfectly safe to watch the video game
retailer released a statement saying
gamestop recently received notification
from a third party that a believed
payment card data from cards used on the
gamespot com website was being offered
for sale on a website that day a leading
security firm was engaged to investigate
these claims gamestop has and will
continue to work non-stop to address
this report and take appropriate
measures to eradicate any issue that may
be identified we'll report back as this
story unfolds so make sure to LIKE and
subscribe to stay up-to-date but in the
meantime gamestop is advising customers
to keep an eye on their account
statements you probably shouldn't worry
until things are confirmed so why don't
you just sit back enjoy your new switch
and watch our video on the 7 best armor
sets in zelda breath of the wild
[Music]